you
you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast nano meter accuracy
distance measurements between floors at
the single molecule level presented by
dr. Nico Stormin and dr. Marston
Bartowski
I'm Christie jewel of lab rats and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminars brought
to you by laberd's and sponsored by
tandoor
for more information on our sponsor
please visit and/or calm
now I would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them in the ask a question
box and click send
while answers many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation just use that
ask a question box and let us know
you're having a problem I'd now like to
introduce our presenters dr. Nico
Stormin research specialist University
of California San Francisco Howard
Hughes Medical Institute also speaking
dr. Martha Marzuki imaging application
specialist and/or
complete biographies on our speakers
please visit the biography tab
dr. Stormin and dr. Bartowski you may
begin your presentations
you
thank you very much crispy for that
production I want to present this word
that started almost 10 years ago in our
lab and it was kind of triggered by my p
i-- wrong wrong fill our lab always has
been doing a lot of single molecule
imaging and this is more the biophysical
single molecule imaging where we label
proteins and then look at proteins on
the cover slips under the microscope and
he was wondering why we couldn't push
the resolution of dual color labeled
distance measurements down into the
nanometer regimen it always seemed like
a big stretch to me but nevertheless put
some work towards that over the years
but never got anywhere near that we
really want it to be until this
brilliant graduate student Stephan
Stephanie come join that lab and really
put a lot of effort into making this
happen and figuring out where the
stumbling blocks actually were and so to
give you a little bit of a background
why we wanted to do this as you may
realize there are other tech techniques
such as few lessons or first or
resonance energy transfer that can
measure distances between fewer fours at
the nanometer resolution so with prep
tends to work best around a distance of
like five nanometers let's say roughly
two to eight nanometers when you go to
direct localization of single molecules
and multiple single molecules it is
definitely possible and it was possible
for a long time to measure distances
down to like authority or with a lot of
effort maybe twenty nanometers but
getting lower has always proved to be
very difficult and yeah hard to achieve
and so with our method that I'll be
presenting here we kind of are filling
this gap and why is this gap so
interesting well a lot of macromolecules
that we want to understand whose
function we want to unless
and that we would like to study under
the month microscopes are actually in
this side regimen so having a technique
available within which you can see
changes in distance up in distill
between like five and twenty five
nanometers is highly highly useful again
to the types of experiments that we are
doing our lab is actually has been
interested in molecular motor proteins
and especially the motor protein
keynesian and dining and so we we have a
lot of technology available to attach
fluorescent labels on these molecules
we'd like to put two differently colored
labels on them and then see and measure
their distance
for instance depending on the nucleotide
state or possibly even while these
molecular motor proteins are moving on
the microtubule matters so what do these
experiments look like I'm showing you
here a more or less raw image and this
raw image for clarity is actually of the
the beads that we use for registration
so we get single molecules in two
different colors there they're off step
here to each other and that is because
we don't align the two images perfectly
in the microscope itself so when we now
blow one of these two spots up you see
that they are well we have a red and a
blue spot here they're clearly displaced
and then that is what we feed into our
analysis software that uses the gaussian
v maximum likelihood estimate with a
gaussian model to determine the center
location of that spot and that center
location has a certain uncertainty
associated with it that I kind of try to
represent here in this ball around the
center then we register the coordinate
systems of these two colored spot
and then you end up with the two colors
close together with a certain distance
apart from each other and what we now
really want to know is how far it will
spot from not respo so that brings us to
the problem of how to measure distances
and then when we go back to elementary
school if you have two points in space
and you want to measure the distance you
use something like a yardstick or a
measuring stick and you you try to find
the center of the one spot and the
center of the other spot and you get a
distance and that is usually already a
pretty good distance estimate and if you
were I really want to know it precise
you do it a couple of times you get a
couple of distance estimates and then
you calculate the every problem so
complicated formula that basically gets
that just gets you the average of these
measurements now that's all very clear
and fine but we have a situation in
which our two spots are relatively close
together and there's a rather big
uncertainty in where exactly their
centers are located and that uncertainty
is kind of on the order of the distance
of the two so when we now try to measure
the distance between them we we get a
certain probability that we think the
center is here and here and a certain
probability doesn't stare and there and
so when we now measure these things can
we just take the average just like we
did here or are there better ways of
estimating the distance now so luckily
for us others already thought about this
and when we repeat those thought
experiments when we now replace one of
these spots where we don't exactly know
where the center is and say okay we
let's pretend we know exactly where
these red spot rate Center was
then the distance to the center of this
blue spot can be given by a circle so
all these points on this part of the
circle are at the exact same distance
however when we now try to figure out
where the center where this one is
actually located our estimates will be
distributed according to the intensities
here of the blue that you see around it
and so you can start to see that on
average most of these more estimate of
this will be outside of the circle then
inside of the circle and so that means
that our estimate for the distance if we
would just do a simple average it would
be too large and now this problem gets
of course compounded if we throw in the
uncertainty of this other spot so
clearly we are not getting a precise
distance estimate by just doing a simple
averaging and Stephane did a lot of
Montecarlo simulations and for this
Monte Carlo simulations we on the x-axis
we err we put the real distance so for
instance think here a real business of
one let's say this is 10 nanometers if
we have an uncertainty sorry so we have
here the only x-axis we have the
uncertainty with which we can localize
the distance there's Sigma D the
standard deviation in the distance so
when the standard deviation is very
small then our error in the distance
measurement is also very small and
clearly when the uncertainty in that
distance goes up then also our error in
our estimate using an average goes up
significantly and so you can see here
that the uncertainty in the distance is
almost linear with the error when we're
using a simple averaging
so can we do better than simple
averaging well it turns out that others
already thought about this problem and
sterling churchmen in Jim's footages lab
at Stanford as a graduate student came
up with this probability density
distribution function that and that that
probability density distribution
function has the measured distance in it
the hunted distance uncertainty as well
as the actual distance and so when we
now do a lot of measurements of the
measured distance and then fit to this
function the distance uncertainty as
well as the actual distance you can
actually get out a under certain
circumstances a better estimate for what
the real distance is and so here if the
error in area this is again the skipper
plot of the year averaging the simple
averaging method and the error that we
get as a function of the distance
uncertainty where we now use this into
the method that we call you the
churchmen PD you see that for a distance
uncertainties below one this method
performs a lot better and are at the
error in our distance measured estimate
becomes a lot lower however when we go
to higher distance uncertainty we still
have a significant error and now to put
this a little bit in made possibly more
easier to understand paragraphs if we
have a real distance of 10 nanometers an
uncertainty of three point seven to
seven point five nanometers we get a
very good estimate of that real distance
of ten nanometers but when the distance
uncertainty goes up and when it becomes
higher than the actual distance our
distance
completely steals so what this tells us
is that this p.2d method helps but it
certainly doesn't do miracles especially
if the uncertainty in the distance is
larger than the actual distance so are
there ways of getting around that and so
first of all to to kind of explain why
this is happening it's useful to look at
plots of the probability distribution
function so when we plot a function for
a real distance of ten point five
nanometers and a sigma in the distance
of eleven nanometers you see that that
function looks extremely similar to the
function the same function for a real
distance of 0.3 nanometers and a stick
minded distance measurement of 13 and a
half nanometers so what happens when
you're fitting these functions with a
higher Sigma T is that the state kind of
converges to a distance of zero which is
wrong but that is the best estimate
given these parameters and so that is
the reason why at a higher Sigma we get
this error of 10 of about 10 nanometers
you know this because the estimate is
actually zero nanometers where it
shouldn't be 10 now so looking at this
formula it already kind of shows we want
to know that real discontinue we are
measuring this distance R so if there's
something that we can do with this
uncertainty in the distance that stick
McGee and so when you think about that
that Sigma D actually is given by the
error that we do in our image
registration and that is something that
we can measure and I will talk about
that later
it is a function of the error in the
localization of the first thought in the
second spot and then actually the
squared the Sigma squares of those
localization errors also propagate in
this area that's just because of error
propagation rules but these two these
last things are also all things that
follow from our MLA Gaussian fit so
these are basically things we know
so the leap that we made was do now
instead of fitting in a fitting function
the Sigma D is to actually measure it
with other ways and then fixing it in
the fit and so that we are only fitting
one variable rather than two and that we
get a better estimate out so when we go
back to the churchmen T to be so and
again these are these graph are actually
all Monte Carlo simulations this is the
same graph that I showed you before when
we now fix B Sigma D since we know it
and then do the same v however all of a
sudden drops and what this says is that
even when the uncertainty in that
distance is twice as large as a distance
itself given enough measurements we can
still measure it very very precise and
so this is
quite a dramatic drops here at higher
stigmas and this method we call a streak
Matthew 2d and it's kind of the biggest
for us this was the biggest mental
breakthrough understanding how to
analyze these data so now doing the
experiments so we use these cover slips
on like a little double sticky flour
cell with three lanes we flowing
fiducial markers which are debt respect
beads beads of Cirrus multiple channels
in the top and bottom rain and then have
our actual sample that we want to
measure in the middle name the
microscope looks something like this we
it is based on a Nikon G I base it has
an ultra stable stainless steel stage it
then has the camera and DM CCD camera
directly attached to a left forward in
the second one to the right port and so
there's an image splitting dichroic in
the base itself and then there's a turf
elimination path that that's called
built so we illuminate with turf and we
take a one color image on one camera and
the other color on the other camera and
we can switch relatively fast between
the two now when we take these images of
the fiducials
beeps they very much look like this but
we want these spots and so here you can
easily tell which blue spots belongs to
which red spot but we want a lot of
those in the end we want to end up with
like 10,000 of these crucial pairs
distributed over the whole image so we
simply translate these bead images by a
micron or something and we take
something like 400 of these so that we
get like every point in the image well
covered with these producers
and then when we calculate an f-1
transform out of all those fiducials and
then correct the positions of these
spots with that we end up with a pattern
like this and here red indicate and this
is the offset in X and red indicates a
high offset and blue indicates a
negative offset and so what is very
clear is that there with an global
f-fine transform there are local
variations that will lead to a huge
error in our samples if we would apply
this so strategy that we use is that for
every point that we want to know its
location we now select control points in
the immediate vicinity so we have some
rules that we want at least ten of these
control points and we don't want it
further than a few microns away and
using that we can get the registration
map to look something like this where
you see that the errors are a very
evenly distributed then when we now
average all those errors we end up with
the total average error and you see that
in this particular experiment that error
was zero nanometers so the registration
of this second set of beads worked very
very well however one thing that we did
note is that the standard deviation here
at the precision was quite a bit lower
than or the number was higher so it was
on the order of five nanometers whereas
we had enough photons that it should
really be much lower and we wondered
what was going on with that I'll get
back to that in a little bit first of
all when we now look at multiple
experiments and then plus the error in X
as well as Y you see that for most of
these experiments we had in total error
of less than one nanometers and we
decided to set
the cutoff so when the error was more
than one nanometer like in these cases
we would simply not use that data and
repeat it so on average on registration
error was always less than one nano
ingot now as I started to tell here this
spread was higher than what we thought
it should be and we were wondering
whether there was a problem in our
registration in the alignment the
registration procedure order there was
something else going on and therefore
step on step that these two different
positions and calculated for each
individual beat so all this data here in
this rectangle came from one in the same
bead and you see that so even though
we're now using different fiducials
to register this bead its distance is
very reproducible so strangely enough
these disrespect beads have color
centers that can be displaced and the
only reason that our alignment procedure
actually works with the uses that we
have so many of them that we averaged
out this displacement of the color
centers so one possible improvement
would be to find bright objects that
fluoresce on both channels and not
overlap exactly and so the first
biological validation that we did I use
this my favorite motor protein kinesin
so kinesin can be righter bound to my
captures the distance between the two
heads of a keynesian dimer in this rider
bound state is known very well and we
can but label the keynesian dimer with
two different colors fluorescently and
so that is what spectrum used to - see
it's the method worked well and so you
see here the distribution of twelve
hundred and sixty one of these kinesin
dimers
and that is stated here in orange with
this Sigma P to D and in this experiment
we measured a distance of 8.5 nano
meters with a sigma d of 7.9 nanometers
you see how favorably that compares to
for example churchmen to the procedure
or a simple gaussian fit of this
distribution and when stefan repeatedly
experiment a couple of times you got
measured and then distance of 0.5
nanometers with the standard error of
the mean of 0.3 nanometers so basically
3 angstroms and that still amazes me
that we are able with a fluorescence
microscope at the third floor
centrifuges nearby to do measurements
that go down into the angstrom precision
now we were very happy with that of
course however what we then started
realizing is that when we measured other
samples that the sigma e55 never worked
very well and it turned out that was
something that we kind of had forgotten
about and that is that in this case in
example the distance is very
reproducible from Keynesian to Keynesian
however most biological samples that is
not the case in molecule a will have a
different distance and molecule B and
then pulling the data like this just
doesn't work very well so the only way
to get on with that is to do multiple
measurements of each individual molecule
and so when you do that there you
immediately have a choice so when you
now do multiple measurements we can
average all these distances together and
say that is our measurement for that
single molecule or what one
can do is first average the positions of
all of the of the type of the distance
measurement at one spot and every folder
positions at the other spot and then
measured is one distance between these
averaged spot positions and the second
method is what we call vector and it
turns out that works a lot better than
the first method and so even using those
vector measurements and again these are
now Monte Carlo simulations just vector
averaging a hundred molecules a vector
averaging them over ten frames shows you
that even with a sigma deal of twofold
the actual distance the distance
estimate is still pretty good like it's
still within like twenty percent of the
real distance however when we now
combine our 2d measurements with that
vector approach you see that we we do
make a significant improvement so this
vector P 2d is what we use for it and
measuring all single molecules that
differ in size so to go back to our
formula for uncertainty in the distance
basically we need to add a term here
that captures the variation in the
sample itself the standard deviation of
the sample and by analyzing the same set
of data with this vector field E and
Sigma P 2d we can see whether it's
simple is homogeneous or heterogeneous
and I can tell you the most biological
samples will be heterogeneous
so we validated the vector P 2d approach
using DNA origamis these DNA origamis
have been designed with two colors at a
distance of about 10 nanometers so these
were made by the company data clumps and
they have actually three color Centers
for each color close by their fitting on
all the ghosts that have a certain
breathing distance and so when we know
each of these when we measure them lot
of times we can find single individual
molecules for which we measure a
distance of in this case twenty five
five point seven and sixteen point three
nanometers so this goes to show the
difference that we can see between
individual molecules but we can measure
each of these with a high precision so
when we now pull the data in this case
that is for like almost 1500 of these
origamis
we see that the vector P 2d approach
gives us exactly the expected average
distance where the vector approach
actually fills us and we did this for
DNA origami of 10 20 and 40 nanometers
in length and these are all three
independent experiments and you see how
linear and the distances aren't of the
measured year so this gave us enough
confidence to trust our vector to be
approached
so within so Stefan's project this PhD
project actually concerns the larger
molecular mode motor protein dining
dining office functions as a dimer a
consists of a large triple-a triple-a
ATPase domain separated by a relatively
long coiled coil to the microtubule
binding domain and still one of the the
main questions in the field is how ATP
hydrolysis in this triple aid domain
propagates itself into changes
microtubule affinity for this coiled
coil very very far away so Stefan had
used one of these dining in this case a
monomer and look at it under the
electron microscope so these are
negative eeehm stains where he used a TB
vanadate that kind of mimics the ATP
bound state where he sees the mic the
coiled coil stock and a microtubule
binding domains sticking out clearly out
of the ATPase domain and then the 8
balls or the no atoms in phosphate bound
state and he basically could not locate
that coiled coil and like a triple
binding domain granville however that is
not a definite argument for a change
means that we cannot stick it there
anymore so he ended up labeling that
dining molecule in a triple-a ATPase
domain with a size three on the go and
of them my microtubule binding domain
with ethyl 647 and then using some
clever short DNA eligos bound both of
these to a layer of streptavidin that
was sitting on the cover state class so
these molecules land on there and
they're integrative either with the pH P
vanadate or they're in the April state
so we know to renew to expect for the
ATP vanadate that we should get a
distance between these two colors of
about twenty nanometers and the question
was what was happening in the ATP
vanadate state and so after analyzing
many of these molecules
Stefan found that for the April
prevented eight states we found in
distance of eighteen point five
nanometers whereas in the APIs case the
distance was eleven point two nine years
showing that there's a very clear kind
of change in conformation and possibly a
local and melting of that coiled coil
bringing these the microtubule binding
domain much closer to the actual motor
domain so at the moment he is interested
in seeing how dining is stepping and so
he is now trying to work these
measurements into dynamic measurements
where we can see changes in distance as
the the two microtubule binding domains
move on the my teachables
so very quickly be all the code that we
use is available in this micromanager
localization microscopy plugin can be
downloaded from the micro manager
website all the source code is also
available online and the methods have
been published in this PNAS paper where
this do do I can then get you going so I
hope this will really inspire people to
start doing similar similar single
molecule distance measurements
it really is doable although it is
finicky to get everything set up right
and get it going and with that I want to
thank our whole lab our lab is a really
great inspiring environment we have a
lot of very gifted and talented postdocs
and graduate students and it's a great
pleasure to work with them all we're at
UCSF and sponsored by M Roseville might
be Eisenhower choose Medical Institute
investigator and with that I will hand
this over to Marshall
hello and welcome to this second part of
webinar and thanks very much to lab
roots and to Nico for introduction and
in this part of our webinar I wanted to
build a little bit on what Nico has
earlier mentioned in context of imaging
done in this research that he has
presented and that's why I chose the
topic of EMCC technology used for
low-light imaging and I'll spend a few
minutes talking about what EMC CDs are
and what are the applications
technological underpinnings of it as
well as future for these kind of imagers
so we have heard about sensitivity and I
think we all probably can agree that
sensitivity is a very important feature
to have in your imaging system
regardless of what camera type and
microscope type and microscope modality
you are using but why do we need
sensitivity and what is sensitivity when
we talk about this in context of cameras
or point detectors
well before we actually talk about
sensitivity in the technological context
and meaning of this word the question
why do we need it is is quite complex
and I think there are multi angled
answers that one can come up with to
this question I mean some of these some
of the reasons why we need sensitivity
are listed here and they may combine
multiple bullet points I have listed so
you know you may have a light star of
sample like in case of the previous
study we have seen earlier today you may
have single molecules which only may
emit a low number of photos and of
course then if you have a low number of
photos to begin with then taking into
account all the losses among the light
paths you will end up with extremely low
number of these photons reaching your
detector bayed a camera or a point
detector your sample may be very dynamic
which means that you will need to have
many frames per second to faithfully
image that and because you have so many
frames per second that means that each
frame lasts for relatively short period
of time reducing therefore the amount of
integration that you are having per one
frame and then there may be a low label
density so for example you know you may
you may only end up with one or or a few
fluorophore molecules attached to your
molecule of interest to minimize impact
on that molecule to maybe avoid reducing
its mobility its movement across
membranes or a number of other steric
hindrance related issues if it's a live
sample life cell type setup you probably
want to lower the excitation power just
to avoid photo toxicity and photo damage
to your cell to your molecules inside
that cell and then last but not least
depending on quantum yields of your
fluorophores you may need to
a deal with low number of photons
emitted abour upon absorption of
excitation photon which may have bearing
on the excitation power that you are
using so as you can see there are
different interconnections between
various reasons you know and there will
be some kind of resultant compromise
that you will have to take into account
when discussing sensitivity and when
deciding for a sensitive sensor for
experiment and this of course will have
additional trade-offs on top of it some
of these trade-offs will be directly
related to what I just said about the
fluorophore properties dynamic sample
etc etc and this can be simplified to
this to this magic triangle so to speak
triangle of sensitivity speed and
resolution and for many many years these
three properties were competing with
each other when you were looking at them
from a point of a detector you could
have any two of these you could have
sensitivity and speed or speed and
resolution and sensitivity and
resolution but not all of not all three
of them because if you try to do that
for example if you have speed and
sensitivity then that means that you
will not have good resolution because
pixels will be probably large because if
large pixels you will have fewer pixels
to deal with because you have fewer
pixels your your image your frame is
smaller to digitize by the camera so you
can go fast but you will not have
resolution conversely if you want to
have resolution and sensitivity
well then resolution will call for small
pixels because you have smaller pixels
you will have more of them and then
because there are more pixels the camera
takes longer to digitize them so that
will of course impact the speed says it
everything will also drop because the
smaller the pixels become the less light
they can absorb per pixel area and so
there are multiple trade-offs to be
aware of some of these trade-offs have
been addressed
with the advent of CMOS cameras or
scientific CMOS cameras however AMC
series as we will see later still
remained the high-end solution for light
starved imaging
so from the point of camera sensitivity
we primarily talk about two key
parameters one of them is so-called
quantum efficiency basically a a
proportion a factor a percentage factor
that will tell you how many photons
reaching the camera will be converted
into photoelectrons and of course the
higher the better the top end cameras
EMCC DS or CMOS will be will have this
factor in the range of ninety five
ninety seven percent for green yellow
part of the e/m spectrum the error
factor is the noise floor and that's
basically some of different noises that
a camera or a point detector will have
there are many different components to
this suffice to say that you want the
noise floor to be as low as possible and
the quantum efficiency as high as
possible and in this situation you can
ensure that your low-light signal will
be detected by the camera and down to
the photon level in some cases
and that's why EMC DS cameras have been
introduced quite a while ago almost 20
years ago and they were introduced as a
high-performance alternative to slow
scan see cds CC these were great because
they had very low noise they had very
good quantum efficiency but they
suffered from low speed he couldn't
really image at video frame rates or
beyond you were limited to maybe a few
frames per second and if the sensor was
larger for example if you wanted to
image you know 2 megapixel or four
megapixel field of view with a ccd that
may have meant one frame or less than
one frame per second and that wasn't
just fast enough for many lifes and
applications so upon their arrival
EMC CDs have been really the cameras of
choice or they have become canons of
choice because of their single photon
sensitivity because of the e/m gain
which I'll talk a little bit about in
the next couple of slides they have
eliminated the read knowledge detection
limit so you know you could really
disregard the noise figure that a CCD
would have if that was for example two
electrons noise of a CCD e/m cameras
have rendered this
electron and virtually zero read noise
and high quantum efficiency like I said
and then you could achieve fast frame
rates achieving sometimes thousands of
frames with so-called image cropping if
you didn't need the full field of view
the full field of view you could
probably achieve anywhere between 30 and
60 frames per second you know for a 4-1
megapixel sensor and they like I said
remain high-end choice for light starved
experiments where you are dealing with
sometimes single photons or a few
photons
like we have seen previously for single
molecule threat and turf combinations
okay so we have now talked about EMC CDs
that reduce the read out dose and they
can be great tools for low-light imaging
but how do they achieve this and in this
slide I have a couple of figures that
illustrate the process behind this
electron multiplication so there are not
animations there are stills but I hope
that you will get the idea really really
quickly
on the left hand side we can see a
typical frame transfer design of these
sensors that you capture your image in
this case this chili pepper in the image
area then this image is shifted directly
under the mask this storage area is
masked with opaque metal mask on top of
it and then image gets slowly read out
in this readout register so you
basically did you shift this pixel row
by pixel and then digitized pixels or
shift pixels individually along these
registers and you can see that there is
a gain register in addition the readout
register and that's where the
multiplication happens so that's where
the where the electrons are multiplied
before are before they are digitized in
this digital converter and because the
the digitization step is where the noise
is added so to speak if you can multiply
your signal before it is converted then
you are reducing the noise contribution
proportionally so it's not that the
noise becomes zero
just as the signal becomes so much
larger in relation to that noise and
this multiplication is achieved in a way
that you can see here on the right hand
side that there are a few pixels
Illustrated here of the e/m gain
register and these electrons that were
created as a result of photon impinging
on the sensor they are passing through
these pixels of E and gain register and
they are multiplied it's basically like
what I would like to call a snowball
effect that you create more and more
more electrons with every step and
because there are hundreds of these e'en
gain pixels you end up with very high
gain levels so in this still we can see
there are some of these
passing through that register and then
in the next stage they are accelerated
with a high-voltage step to create more
secondary electrons and this is repeated
over and over again to create a large
number of electrons corresponding to the
initial input value that was created by
single or maybe a few photons arriving
at the sensor
and that's how it looks like in context
of a real sample so you know that's how
EMC CD gain works and what it produces
you have some single molecules here
shown here on the left at different Ian
gain levels and then you can clearly see
that with the increasing gain you
basically increasing on the noise ratio
and then your signal becomes visible and
can be acquired at that level and that
analyzed further for in your data
analysis suite
so probably most of you have heard and
maybe used scientific CMOS cameras or s
CMOS cameras so how do these compare to
EMC CDs you know so this is a very basic
comparison of the single molecule type
setup where we are acquiring images
across number of exposures and you can
probably notice that with iam camera you
start to see something in the range of
tens of milliseconds you know you start
to get enough still on the noise
separation that you probably could do
something with this at 50 milliseconds
and with the CMOS cameras you probably
will need you know ten times longer
exposure in such conditions of course
that differs and that depends on the
CMOS camera whether it's a front or back
illuminated camera but by and large EMC
CDs will outperform CMOS cameras for
this extremely low light signal levels
and this is shown in this signal to
noise ratio plot where you can see that
for example when we look at our two
cameras X is an AM CCD so nice is our
scientific CMOS you see that for low
values of photons per pixel extremely
well essentially single photons your AM
camera will always outperform a CMOS
camera once you get to you know to the
regime of tens of photons per pixel per
exposure and above then situation
changes somewhat and then your CMOS
camera will turn will deliver a better
looking image
so what is the future of EMC CDs in
light of these as CMOS cameras well I
think it's it's first to say that for
single molecule fluorescence and low
light imaging EMCC this will remain
cameras of choice and this is just just
because the the sheer sensitivity
combined with E and gain application and
that you know if you are imaging single
molecules like what I have seen earlier
today if you are combining these single
molecule imaging studies with rapid and
sometimes real-time imaging you really
need to have best ignore the noise ratio
delivery tool and such tool is an aim
CCD camera I think this also becomes
valid when you try to do some
multiplexed imaging you're looking at
different wavelengths coverages e/m
cameras will deliver sensitivity across
the entire quantum efficiency curve of
course there will be some drop-off
towards extreme blue or extreme far red
but if these if these molecules these
specimens you're trying to image are
broadly in the invisible then these
cameras will be always delivering
sensitivity or quantum efficiency in the
range of 95 90 90 95 percent I think
interestingly in in cases of multimodal
imaging combining for example AFM and
turf or maybe time-resolved so doing
more unusual combinations that that may
have been the case in the past 10 years
and these cameras offer that flexibility
that you know you can combine AFM and
turf and look at these single molecules
and you will still get a very nice very
good signal-to-noise ratio and for
example you can maybe reduce the
vibration that the camera produces that
may be maybe an important factor for AFM
setup you can switch off the fan for
some time and then you will have some
time maybe a few minutes depending on
fathom how deeply cooled the camera is
to acquire images at complete standstill
with with no vibration coming from the
camera so there are still lots of life
in AMC's new technologies I believe but
it is also fair to say that CMOS cameras
are making inroads into this field
thanks to increases in speed and
sensitivity however e/m is still the the
main differentiating factor between CMOS
and EMC CDs and I think that will remain
the case for the foreseeable future
so thank you very much for your
attention I hope you found this
informative and you have any questions
about any of these camera technologies
or come or cameras that you would like
to find out more please drop me an email
on the email address I have added here
and thanks very much for your attention
thank you bye bye
thank you dr. Stormin and dr. Barsky for
your informative presentations we will
now start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar now if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen then we will
answer as many questions we have time
for okay let's get started and we have
some great questions coming in dr.
Stormin let's start with you what
settings did you use for image
acquisition exposure camera settings etc
yeah that that's especially in light of
Martha's presentation I think that that
is a fun question
so Stefan put a lot of work in figuring
out what his what the best settings were
and remarkably even though we have en
CCD cameras which in part is because we
built this microscope already in 2011
before the most cameras became popular
and he found that it was better for him
to not use the electron multiplication
registry but rather used the classical
readout mode of the camera in part that
is because we could go to long exposure
times these single molecules were not
moving so you used a slow readout mode
of the camera you read it out at 3
megahertz which reduces the readout
noise and that also limited his exposure
time to something on the order of 300
milliseconds if I remember correctly so
it is kind of of interest to me whether
we would be able to get better
localization precision with the CMOS
camera versus this classical CCD readout
mode but in this mode we were able to
get these very high precision distance
measurements
Thank You dr. Sherman now don't suppose
50 of us come over to you do you think
that the EMC CDs will ever be superseded
by CMOS cameras and if yes when well
thank you very much for this question I
think it's a really interesting one and
I keep hearing it more and more
frequently I think the CMOS scientific
CMOS cameras have become so widely use
these days that I think it's only
natural that people keep asking question
when if ever they become as good as the
old yen CDs and I think well they're
it's not easy to really to answer this
question because I think no
fundamentally and CMOS will never be as
as sensitive as EMC CDs when it comes to
the fact that Reed knows Indian cameras
can be essentially suppressed you know
to separate from levels thanks to the en
game CMOS cameras will not have it for
the foreseeable future and simply
because we would need to apply a
built-in en gain on a single pixel level
and then of course these games would
differ across the entire matrix of a lot
of chips so we end up with 4 point 2 or
5 point 5 million yen registers with
their own variants so I think it's it's
fair to say that I think Ian's cameras
will remain dominant especially for
these extremely light starved conditions
when you really need to apply high and
gain settings to suppress the readout
noise so there may be time were CMOS
cameras reduce their readout noise so
much that they start to approach these
really low light regimes capable of
being addressed by en cameras but I
would say that still number of years
away
thank you dr. preczewski now this asks
question I'll throw out to both of you
now a CMOS camera is not as good as MCCD
below 500 but why do some labs use CMOS
cameras for single molecule fret
experiments
you
Neko be 100 in error
well maybe I can start I think that
maybe the parameter below 500
milliseconds is a little too simplistic
I think what it really comes down to is
the photon flux so how many photons do
you get per exposure and so if your
photon flux is in the couple of
electrons per 500 milliseconds so a
couple of photons per 500 milliseconds
level then the EMCC D will definitely
perform better whereas when that photon
flux is higher you will have you
possibly could have an attached using
the CMOS in our single molecule
experiments we find a few thousand
photons per exposure so that would
actually be based on that already in the
regimen where this CMOS could have a
higher signal noise ratio but maybe you
want to expand on that mark yes I think
it's a really really valid point Niko
that it really boils down to the photon
flux and what I didn't really discuss in
detail in my presentation is that
whenever we look at these sensitivity
curves they are really done on a per
pixel number of photons per pixel per
exposure basis
so you're right you know if you are
looking at really low flux per unit time
you will need an e in ccd camera but if
the flux is is is higher then CMOS may
well be as good as an e/m CCD so it
really depends on the application a lot
and I think that's why we always out
always recommend comparing the two
cameras if that's possible because now
you may realize that you don't need em
and and and it's image may be perfectly
desirable solution for that experiment
thank you gentlemen dr. Sturman let's
come back over to you did you acquire
the two-channel images simultaneously or
sequentially and why yes so in principle
we would love to acquire them
simultaneously and that's also how we
build the microscope so there's an image
splitting dichroic mirror within the
microscope so that we can expose it to
cameras at the same time however we
found that when we excite the dye of the
lower wavelength in our case it dies
like size reeds we get a significant
amount of background in the higher
wavelength channel in the sci-fi channel
and that background is caused by things
like the oil the oil immersion and even
the glass of the objectives as well as
the sample holders so this background is
very detrimental to localization
precision and because of that reason we
had to take these images sequentially
and we put a lot of effort into setting
up the system so that we can get the two
images very rapidly one after another so
ideally simultaneously because of
practical reasons sequentially
thanks dr. Sherman now let's have you
answer this next time can this technique
be extended to more colors
absolutely and again we can do that with
two cameras because we acquire the
images sequentially and Stefan right now
is is doing experiments in which uses
three labels one is using protein and
localize those three with respect to
each other
Thank You dr. Sturman now we're almost
out of time doctor particulates how do
you answer this last question can-am
CCDs be used to detect single photons
with the same precision as single point
detectors the short answer is no and
just because of the properties of noise
that these sensors have and single con
detectors are designed precisely for
detecting and single photons but they
are limited by the fact that they are at
point detector so they cannot take an
image a camera and the N CCD camera will
take an image it can be an extremely low
light image but because of the noise
distribution and uncertainty on top of
the multiplication process you may
remember the one I talked about the e/m
gain register cascading electrons
through the register there is certain
distribution of of electrons that are
being created and because of the
different distributions of you know
likelihoods availabilities occurring in
the camera you will never be able to say
that that was exactly one photon or two
photons hitting that pixel so you know
these cameras will not deliver the same
detection capability a single point
however they take they can take an image
which sometimes is what you exactly need
you have a larger to the area and
scanning that area with a single point
attackers would just take too much time
in case there is a very rapid process
occurring any one to capture the process
in its entirety without risking losing
some details of this by line by line
scanning
thank you doctor pursue ski now before
we go I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today down for their
interesting questions those questions we
did not have time to answer today and
those that will be submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speakers via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
I would like to once again thank dr.
Niko's Thurman and dr. Marcin bar Susie
for their time today and for their
important research we would also like to
thank labyrinth and our sponsor and or
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
now this webcast can be viewed on-demand
and labret swill alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event thanks for joining us
and we hope to see you again soon
bye bye